imposter phenomenon is quite strong
among perfectionists you look around and
see people are doing so much better than
you or how you think you're doing so
much better than you and you think
inside I have to prove every day I'm
good enough success is a bottomless pit
it depletes Us in its Pursuit and just
like the Horizon it keeps slipping away
the further we get to it this is how
perfectionism operates within the
mindset of people and so of course you
know when things don't go well we're
going to turn on ourselves because we
weren't perfect in that moment you are a
human being you exist so you are enough
and I think that's the most important
lesson to take through life something to
remember all the time when things go
well things don't go quite so well it's
okay you're human we fail you are enough